is Apple falling behind well we're gonna
answer that in today's video because we
have the iPhone 15 Pro Max right here
and Samsung's Galaxy s23 Ultra and we're
gonna compare everything including the
designs displays cameras speakers
performance overheating and much more
getting straight into the designs the
iPhone 15 Pro Max has generally the same
design language as we've had since the
11 Pro but this is the new blue titanium
model and it is really really dark
almost like a navy blue I actually kind
of like it the only issue is the
fingerprints on the sides I thought the
titanium would get rid of that but
honestly it almost looks like it has
worse fingerprints than the stainless
steel on the s23 ultra now both of them
have a curved design especially on the
Samsung but I love the new curved edges
on the 15 Pro Max it really makes it
feel a lot more comfortable in your
hands and it honestly makes it feel
thinner than the previous 14 pro Max
even though it's slightly thicker now
compared to this one they're basically
the same in terms of thickness but I
don't like this Square design where it
kind of digs right into your palm it
kind of gets annoying this is just such
a massive phone compared to the nice
soft curved edges on the 15 Pro Max so
I've got to say in terms of comfort the
iPhone is the winner now comparing the
camera bumps they both look really
really good I like how Samsung has this
flush glass design with the lenses right
on the back and I really love apples as
well it looks really really clean with
this kind of glass step out and the
interesting thing is because of this
little glass square it doesn't look like
the camera bump is massive but in
reality it is huge when you look from
the side so much thicker than the one on
the Samsung even though the Samsung
actually has a 10x telephoto lens
compared to the new 5x which Apple
achieved some really interesting stuff
which I'm gonna get into in just a
minute and a 200 megapixel main camera
on the Samsung compared to 48 so I mean
Samsung good job on not having a massive
massive camera bump now one interesting
change that I'm noticing this year is
that finally the iPhone is lighter than
the Samsung only because of the titanium
making it about 10 percent lighter so
this is really nice because the
Samsung's heavier and it's quite a lot
larger like it takes up so much more
room in your pocket now this year the 15
Pro Max has two big things going for it
on the exterior one of them being the
brand new action button which is
actually very unique now the Samsung did
used to have the Bixby button but
everybody hated it because all it did
was turn on Bixby so they basically got
rid of it now you only have the power
button and volume buttons but this
action button is very very cool let me
show you why
listen yep I actually mapped the action
button to run a shortcut that plays an
audio file within the files app as you
can see I'm in the action button
settings you can see I set it to a
shortcut I set it to run my custom Hey
listen
shortcut now you can choose a bunch of
different things like silent mode you
have focus camera you could actually
open up the camera and have it go
straight to a photo or even a selfie a
video a portrait portrait selfie very
customizable flashlight voice memos
short basically anything you want to do
this is a really cool and unique feature
and it's going to be a lot of fun for
people who upgrade and the second big
thing is that Apple finally adopted the
USBC Port now I know a lot of you
Android guys are going to say yeah we've
had that for years but guess what the
iPhone actually has a faster USBC Port
because it supports 10 gigabit per
second transfer speeds while the Samsung
the s23 Ultra that's basically more
expensive only five gigabits per second
so Apple actually came out and beat them
going from only USB 2 speeds at 480
megabits per second to 10 gigs per
second and now the cool thing for iPhone
users this year is that you could charge
a bunch of things with a USBC port for
example I just plugged in the airpods
Pro usb-c to lightning cable really cool
even better
plug in this Razer phone cooler that
connects using Max safe to get rid of
all of the overheating issues that
people are complaining about on the 15
Pro which I'm actually going to get into
later on in this video by the way this
thing gets freezing freezing cold and
you can even charge the s23 ultra from
the iPhone now of course this thing can
basically do all of those things but
it's really cool for iPhone users even
better you might not know this but you
could actually plug in a USBC Hub like
this see it's powering it on I have an
SD card basically a CF Express card
plugged in we can go into the files app
and there you go Untitled this thing is
showing up even better let's plug in
this little SD mini card in there you go
it shows up X8 right there basically you
can plug in a ton of different things
there you go I just plugged in the air
pods it's all running from the iPhone
this is just awesome all of that makes
me very excited because everybody
thought that Apple would limit the crap
out of the USBC Port but they're
basically just letting it go free with
full support just like you have on a
Samsung or other Android device now
while Apple made a great decision
switching to USBC well basically the EU
forced them to do it thank you EU they
have made some questionable decisions
this year and one of them is getting rid
of genuine leather for their cases and
giving us this thing the fine woven case
which is basically like a textile
material let's take it out right here
all right looks really cool and here you
go we have this case let's plop it on
all right now First Impressions it
basically feels like a 90s kind of like
windbreaker jacket like halfway like
really fine denim all around you have
this fine woven material the sides feel
kind of like silicone
but it is still fine woven the big issue
is that it still costs sixty dollars and
it's nowhere near as premium as Apple's
genuine leather cases which they no
longer have and even worse a ton of
people are complaining online about
permanent scratching to the Fine woven
material as well as staining with water
dirt and oils basically it's a terrible
decision to buy One of These Fine woven
cases just like Apple's terrible
decision to get rid of genuine leather
but thankfully we still have third-party
Brands who make genuine leather cases
like our sponsor Nomad who makes both
modern leather cases and folios in a
variety of colors like this one which is
rustic Brown now they're all Max safe
compatible and they now come with these
super high quality metal buttons and for
the perfect upgrade kit you can combine
the leather case with one of their Gan
Chargers like this compact dual Port 65
watt for fast charging two phones at
once using either Ultra Premium double
braided Kevlar USBC cables and you can
order them all today using the links in
the description below and now let's get
into the displays the iPhone has the
same 6.7 inch display as we had last
year no changes at all in terms of the
features while the Samsung has a 6.9
inch so a larger display they both have
120 hertz displays with their adaptive
refresh rate or Pro motion which is
really nice but I do like how the
Samsung just has that little single hole
punch right there at the top compared to
the dynamic Island which I will admit is
very impressive and useful like that
showing up little notifications whatever
else up there very nice animations but
the hole punch is more smooth now one
thing I do like about the iPhone is the
super slim bezels look how slim they are
compared to the Samsung especially the
top and the bottom they just stick out
like a sore thumb so good job apple with
these super thin bezels now they both
get super bright when you manually
adjust them to the Max and honestly
right now the iPhone looks like it's a
little bit brighter than the Samsung and
in terms of the peak brightness the
iPhone will go up to 2 000 nits compared
to around 1750 on the Samsung and yes we
just went outside and we confirmed that
the iPhone display is brighter with full
white screens like the Google home page
as well as ones like The Verge where you
got a lot of darks and very bright
whites the iPhone is still brighter in
both scenarios however when we get into
HDR video in YouTube for some reason the
Samsung is quite a lot brighter for all
these HDR scenes and the colors are
actually popping more because of that so
it's doing a better job I don't know if
it's the tuning or what with the
software but no doubt s23 Ultra is
winning here and now with the displays
out of the way let's jump into the
speaker quality test
[Music]
all right wow guys let me know what you
thought down in the comment section
below but to me the iPhone is actually
louder and it sounds better than the s23
ultra boost is interesting because last
year the s23 ultra actually destroyed
the 14 pro Max so this one actually
matched the 14 and then exceeded it with
a lot more volume bass everything sounds
very good Clarity definitely the winner
in the speaker test and now let's jump
into the performance testing starting
with geekbench 6. as you can see we have
the a17 pro chip right here on the
iPhone clocking at
3.77 gigahertz with eight gigs of RAM on
the Samsung s23 Ultra we actually have
3.36 gigahertz so this should
theoretically have a lower single core
score but with that said let's run the
CPU test and there you go we have our
scores and wow looks like a17 Pro is
still way ahead and the CPU Department
in single core it's 45 faster and for
multi-core 36 faster so definitely way
ahead let's actually test speedometer
2.0 the web browser Benchmark to see the
web browsing performance there's our
score and wow look at that over twice as
fast for General web browsing speed that
might be because the s23 ultra is using
Chrome and the iPhone's using Safari
which is extremely optimized made by
Apple so it fully supports all the
features definitely a winner there now
going back to geekbench let's go ahead
and run the GPU Benchmark metal on the
iPhone Vulcan on the s23 whoa this just
doesn't make sense right here because we
have 27 000 for the iPhone only 9 000
for the Samsung so it seems like for
some reason geekbench 6 is not really
doing well in terms of cross platform
ability so let's do another test here we
have 3D Parks Wildlife extreme unlimited
test for both of them which is very good
at utilizing the gpus for kind of like
gaming performance let's go ahead and
run both of them we got the results and
take a look at that the Samsung is
beating the iPhone in the first test in
the GPU ever so slightly 21fps compared
to 20.8 on the iPhone so yes Apple's a17
Pro GPU is actually falling behind
because Samsung's about to have the New
Gen 3 coming out very soon but now I
want to take it a step further with the
20-minute Wildlife extreme stress test
which is going to show us a chart of the
actual average FPS going down to see
which one's overheating more because
there are reports of the a17 Pro
overheating quite badly because they've
really pushed a lot of wattage to the
chip and the GPU in particular and I got
my little thermal seek camera right here
to see kind of the difference in temps
let's go ahead and start this test
interesting I'm looking at the FPS right
now and the iPhone's actually hitting
about 30 FPS no problem while this
thing's sitting about 22 25 so
definitely smoother FPS on the iPhone so
far whoa it's already going down 12 15.
it's now under the FPS dramatically than
the s23 alter this is really really
weird is it really overheating already
all right now recording The Backs we can
see we have a hot spot on the Samsung
about 41 degrees Celsius pretty hot
going over to the iPhone also 41 degrees
Celsius right now
so really no differences but it does
look like the heat is more spread out on
the Samsung that's probably because of
the vapor chamber cooling which for some
reason apple is refusing to put on their
iPhone look at that 40 it just hit 40
degrees looks like Apple's actually
throttling the a17 pro chip more so
then the s23 ultra is look at that still
41 and now if I just watch the FPS right
now the s23 ultra is running at a higher
frame rate it's clearly more smooth all
right now we only have a couple of
minutes left so what I want to do is
turn these over on the back so that we
get a more accurate thermal reading I'm
gonna separate them just a little bit
and now let's look at these temps right
here the s23 ultra we have 45 degrees
Celsius
then over on here we have look at that
45 degrees Celsius oh 44. so it still is
kind of throttling a little bit and once
again look at the heat Distribution on
that s23 Ultra the whole thing is
spreading the heat whereas we have a
really hot spot on the iPhone which will
tend to give you more throttling because
it's all concentrated there and of
course the s20 ultra is a little bit
bigger so it can handle more heat with a
bigger spread but look at that temps are
actually going down now and there you go
the test is finished and taking a look
at this it actually looks like the
iPhone has fared better first of all the
first test is insanely high for the
iPhone
3996 basically 4 000 compared to the
best Loop score of
3755 for the Samsung so just a little
bit better for the iPhone however you
get a bigger drop on the iPhone with
only stability of 62.5 percent that's
basically the difference between the
best score and the worst score you can
see that huge drop down you can see as
it starts throttling it goes lower and
lower and lower until it finally
reverses a little bit at the very end
whereas with the Samsung you can see
that for the first two tests it's
actually quite even so it's able to keep
the performance higher before throttling
and it gradually gradually goes down to
the bottom and right here you can see
the difference between basically the
best Loop score and the worst one and
the iPhone definitely drops off lower
because of thermal throttling but in the
end it still has a higher lowest Loop
score of 24.98 compared to 2407 so it
looks like the iPhone is still winning
and now let's get into the camera
comparison the really cool new feature
on the iPhone starting with selfies is
this you'll notice when I put the selfie
up to my face you see this little F
button so if I click it it actually
turns on portrait mode instantly because
the AI algorithms actually detected my
face but the coolest part is if you take
a regular selfie and then you go into it
you hit edit you can actually enable
portrait mode by moving this slider
there you go portrait is working from a
regular photo now you can actually
change the focus point of the portrait
mode which is really really awesome
however the s23 ultra actually has
better quality because it has a 40
megapixel selfie camera compared to just
12. you can see instantly that the
quality is a lot better on the Samsung
so it definitely wins for selfies and
now moving on to the ultra wide camera
if you take a look and get a little bit
closer on Max right here you'll notice a
couple of things first of all the HDR is
better on the iPhone because of smart
hdr5 you could actually see this little
building behind him and for some reason
the Samsung has this kind of washed out
gray look almost like a kind of haze
from the room making everything look a
little bit Gray but the quality is
actually better as far as I can tell on
the Samsung for Ultra wides but now
let's get into the new 5x camera on the
15 Pro Max this actually lets you do 5x
portraits which you can see right here
just looking at them
this looks like a professional DSLR
portrait with 120 millimeter focal
length this looks absolutely amazing
with the depth of what kind of rolls off
towards the back this does look pretty
nice but it does kind of seem like it's
a SmartPhone shot and as you get closer
you can see there's a little bit issues
with the portrait mode and if I get
really close and zoom in on his face you
can see that the HDR is not working so
well on the Samsung his face looks all
like really flat doesn't look that good
the detail is kind of missing the darks
are just kind of crushed whereas this
looks absolutely incredible the
Highlight roll up on his face it looks
very natural and the detail and the hair
incredible for the 5x lens of course
compared to the 3x portrait and of
course because we're comparing 3x to 5x
this one's a little bit further away so
what I did is I stepped closer to kind
of match the framing and and as you can
see the 5x lens just has a lot more
compression in the back where everything
just kind of gets larger behind you
where the body get kind of gets smaller
in front it just looks very very nice
and natural compared to a little bit of
distortion because the focal length is
not as high now moving on this is a 1x
portrait which both of them can do
however the iPhone now defaults to 24
megapixel photos with the main sensor
instead of 12 like on the Samsung so if
I do some pixel peeping and really zoom
in on his face right away you can see
more detail on the iPhone the hair
stands out everything looks a little bit
more natural especially with the HDR
making a Space the the lighting just
look more natural compared to these kind
of like highlight spots and you can see
kind of like some compression artifacts
in the face as well and then this right
here is using the 10x camera on the s23
ultra which is a big Advantage for it
compared to the 5x which I digitally
zoomed up to 10. you could definitely
see that we have higher quality on the
s23 ultra all the hair definitely better
quality but we still have that same
issue of his face looking very very flat
because the HDR and processing is just
not as good as what the iPhone can do
with smart hdr5 and then here we have a
far range shot showing off the
difference for kind of detail and text
you can see the 10x right over here
definitely an insane amount of extra
detail on the s23 Ultras 10x camera and
by the way this is actually 25x set on
both of them and here we just went all
out this is a hundred X on the s23 ultra
and 25x which is the maximum for the
iPhone so if we actually zoom in and try
to match up the framing of both of them
you could see that the iPhone just looks
terrible you could barely even tell that
it's a Building compared here to the
Samsung looks a lot better for far range
and here we're comparing the 50
megapixel camera on the Samsung compared
to 48 which is heif Max on the iPhone so
once again let's do some pixel peeping
and as it turns out the iPhone's 48
megapixel looks to be a little bit
better than the 50 on the Samsung and
then here we're actually testing the 200
megapixel camera mode onto the s23 ultra
so let's zoom in really close and
surprisingly the iPhone actually isn't
that far off it's really really close
right here you do see more kind of like
smoothing and compression artifacts here
over sharpening on the iPhone but I do
think the 200 is a little bit better and
then finally I decided to do a 10x low
light shot which basically we had a lot
of the lights off taking a look at the
detail and it looks like the Samsung
actually turns off the 10 next camera
and uses a crop from the main and as you
can see the iPhone has more noise but
it's definitely more detailed because
the 5x lens has a f 2.8 aperture so it
can actually stay on and collect enough
light with low light compared to the 10x
which is like f 4.8 or 4.9 it just
doesn't get enough light so it just
shuts off switches to the main now of
course these are just a couple of tests
but I do want to mention that we're
going to be doing a full unbiased camera
comparison with the iPhone 15 Pro Max
the s23 ultra and the pixel 7 Pro
looking at which camera is the best in
2023 so definitely subscribe so you
don't miss out on that and now with all
that said and tested let's finally
answer the original question is Apple
falling behind compared to the s23 ultra
and honestly
I'm kind of liking it I was expecting to
get worse performance and that stress
test it actually beat it out we have the
new action button we have USBC which is
now faster twice as fast than on the s23
ultra I'd argue you have a better design
language that fits more comfortably in
your hand you have the dynamic Island
and the camera is better in multiple
ways so with that said I've got to say
I'm giving the win to the iPhone 15 Pro
Max now of course we're getting the new
s24 Ultra very soon so we'll have to see
when that comes out and do this test
again so hopefully you enjoy this video
and if you did click the circle above to
subscribe definitely check out the links
for the bataka cases down below and one
of those great videos right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
all right